[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
voyage en arctique pour ceux qui savent
pas l'arctique c'est le grand nord donc
on n'est pas en antarctique dans le
grand sud là où il ya des manchots là je
vous emmène dans les contrées du nord où
il ya des ours polaires et pourquoi je
vous emmène là bas en fait je vous
emmène pour faire un double voyage on va
parler d'arctique c'est vrai mais on va
aussi parler d'hydrogène est en fait ce
qui est très intéressant aujourd'hui en
c'est que ces deux sujets sont en train
de se télescoper
d'un côté il ya cette image d'épinal de
l'article que vous connaissez j'imagine
tous il ya le blanc il ya le froid il ya
les populations autochtones
il y a évidemment la nature il y a
évidemment les développements
économiques aussi et puis au delà de ça
il y à d'autres choses et dans les
développements économiques
il y a le tourisme évidemment sur lequel
le voyage en arctique évidemment
prospère mais au delà du tourisme il y a
donc toutes ses dimensions industrielles
qui pour certaines sont très polluantes
et pour d'autres un petit peu moins et
c'est justement ce sur quoi on va
s'attarder
aujourd'hui donc l'arctique vous le
savez vous le voyez c'est une région qui
est aujourd'hui en difficulté
c'est une région ou tout simplement on a
des grands questionnements par rapport
aux changements climatiques bien sûr et
au modèle de civilisation au modèle de
consommation modèle de production qu'on
a envie de développer pour l'avenir
alors ce que vous voyez derrière moi
tout simplement
c'est la fonte de l'arctique sur les 35
dernières années
vous le savez j'imagine si vous ne le
savez pas je vous invite à regarder ce
qui se passe derrière moi tout
simplement parce que il faut repérer
comment font l'arctique l'arctique ne
font pas de manière uniforme
il ne se passe pas la même chose partout
il n'y a pas un arctique il y a des
arctique et la fonte des glaces elle est
justement donc un multiforme si vous
allez par exemple au large de la russie
il va fondre la glace de fondre beaucoup
on parle ici de la banquise c'est à dire
les glaces de mer
ce que vous voyez donc derrière moi si
vous allez au nord du canada
cette banquise va fondre beaucoup moins
elle ne va pas forcément rendre le ce
qu'on appelle le passage du nord ouest
complètement accessible
alors que de l'autre côté le passage du
nord-est pour acheminer des marchandises
depuis l'europe vers l'asie le long des
côtes russes ou vice versa lui il
s'ouvre alors pourquoi ça s'ouvre à
l'est et pourquoi ça s'ouvre moins
l'ouest iliad est question ici de
courantologie il ya des courses des
questions tout simplement physique des
questions géologique qui explique tout
ça mais ensuite l'autre chose qui
explique que ça se développe plus à
l'est qu'à l'ouest en arctique c'est
tout simplement l'intérêt des
populations locales et l'intérêt en
particulier des décideurs politiques et
financiers qui en russie sont bien plus
intéressés par le développement des
ressources et notamment le développement
des ressources extractives en arctique
que ce qu'on peut trouver par exemple
dans l'arctique américain ou dans
l'arctique canadien
bon après il ya d'autres parties de
l'arctique qui sont aussi très connue
est en fait relativement mal connues
comme par exemple le groenland le
groënland c'est cette terre qui est
grande comme quatre fois la france
au beau milieu de l'arctique qui va
séparer l'arctique européen de
l'arctique nord américains et ceux
groenland comme vous le voyez mais tout
simplement c'est par là que les glaces
partent quand elle partie de l'arctique
pour allez fondre et alimenter tout
simplement le reste des océans donc ce
groenland il a une position qui vaut
talent c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous en avez certainement entendu parler
en 2019
donald trump à l'époque président des
états unis avait proposé d'acheter le
groenland
c'est pas la première fois les états
unis avaient déjà tenté d'acheter du
groenland en 46 1946 mais aussi en 1867
encore avant date à laquelle il avait
déjà acheté l'alaska à la russie
tsariste
alors pourquoi l'arctique attirent tant
bien évidemment cette fonte des glaces
dans l'arctique plus accessible bien sûr
on l'a dit mais au-delà de cette
accessibilité
il ya des questions évidemment d'énergie
qui sont sous jacente est donc la
première question par rapport à
l'énergie c'est tout simplement est ce
que en arctique
on va commencer à exploiter de l'énergie
de la même manière que dans le reste de
la planète
dans le reste de l'histoire pour
l'instant la réponse est oui pour
l'instant l'arctique se développent
comme le reste du monde c'est à dire
principalement focalisée sur les
énergies fossiles pétrole gaz charbon et
l'arctique évidemment est une zone du
monde dans laquelle vous allez voir il y
à de grands
enjeu énergétique puisque
fondamentalement en arctique vous allez
trouver l'un des grand problème qui va
se poser dans les dix prochaines années
à savoir
peut-on changer d'énergie et si oui pour
laquelle ou lesquelles donc ce que vous
voyez maintenant derrière moi c'est tout
simplement le développement des
différentes énergies utilisées dans le
monde depuis le début de l'ère
industrielle donc sur les 200 et
quelques dernières années on avait
d'abord dans les années 1840 une
progression du charbon puis au tournant
du xxème siècle une progression du
pétrole
puis on arrive à la seconde guerre
mondiale et après une progression du gaz
naturel
et puis ensuite dans la deuxième moitié
du 20e siècle l'hydroélectricité on va
trouver les énergies renouvelables
évidemment récemment on va trouver aussi
le nucléaire que vous connaissez bref
tout ça c'est ce que vous voyez derrière
moi et du coup la question qui se pose
véritablement ses petons changer
d'énergie
ce que vous voyez dans ce grave c'est
que jusqu'à maintenant dans notre
perspective de développement industriel
on n'a jamais réussi à faire venir une
nouvelle énergie primaire dans le mix
mondiale et faire en sorte que cette
nouvelle énergie remplacent les énergies
dominante d'avant le pétrole n'a pas
remplacer le charbon le pétrole s'est
additionnée au charbon le gaz naturel
n'a pas remplacé nil pétrole ni le
charbon il le sait qu'additionner au
pétrole et au charbon
pareil pour l'uranium pareil pour
l'hydroélectricité pareil pour les
énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui alors du coup peut-on
changer d'énergie c'est ça la grande
question de la transition énergétique
que tout le monde et c'est évidemment de
développer sans véritablement avoir
forcément toujours les mêmes solutions
alors du coup je vais vous parler de mon
autre coeur d' expertise au delà des
questions polaires c'est l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène pourquoi c'est important en
arctique tout simplement parce que en
arctique
il y a potentiellement beaucoup
d'hydrogène mais il y à de l'hydrogène
qui peut être carbonée à partir donc de
charbon de gaz de pétrole ce qui en fait
ne changerait pas grand chose et puis il
ya de l'hydrogène bas carbone ou
décarbonés par exemple de l'énergie à
partir d'énergies renouvelables et du
coup la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est quel est le point de départ de
tous est toute cette discussion le point
de départ c'est qu'aujourd'hui à
l'échelle mondiale
l'hydrogène vert donc c'est à dire
hydrogène parc produit à partir
d'énergies renouvelables
ça ne représente que 1% de la production
totale d'hydrogène aujourd'hui quand on
dit l'hydrogène va permettre une
transition énergétique décarbonés
l'hydrogène va permettre de régler
toutes les solutions de fait si on
produit l'hydrogène à l'avenir comme on
le fait maintenant ça va rien régler du
tout et ça va d'autant moins réglé les
choses que l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui pour produire 1 kg
d'hydrogène vous allez et m 9 kg de co2
donc fondamentalement si on à 99% de
l'hydrogène qui consomment à un moment
de sa production du carbone bas de fait
on ne règle pas le problème
donc en fait le véritable sujet de
l'hydrogène et on en a parlé déjà
aujourd'hui on en parle régulièrement
dans les médias c'est de passer à
l'hydrogène donc vers renouvelables sauf
que l'hydrogène renouvelables c'est pas
si facile que ça à trouver ça coûte cher
à produire et du coup ça coûte combien
bah vous avez derrière moi aujourd'hui
pour produire 1 kg d'hydrogène
renouvelables on ait un minimum 5 euros
6 euros 7 euros 10 euros du kilo en
fonction donc des rendements en fonction
des technologies en fonction des savoirs
en fonction des logiques aussi des
différents pays en termes de taxation en
termes de facilité de subventions j'en
passe et des meilleurs donc aujourd'hui
5 euros le kilo c'est l'ordre de
grandeur que vous pouvez retenir et pour
que l'hydrogène verts puissent commencer
à opérer une bascule à permettent de
remplacer d'autres énergies dominante et
en particulier je pense ici au charbon
qui est l'énergie fossile la plus
polluante parmi les trois que j'ai cités
tout à l'heure un charbon pétrole et gaz
naturel
eh bien il faudrait que l'hydrogène
puissent être produits de manière verte
donc à partir d'énergies renouvelables à
un prix d'environ 1 euro 50 le kilo
comme vous voyez 5 euros 1 euro 50
on n'y est pas tout à fait mais en
réalité si vous avez suivi l'actualité
ces derniers mois quand vous avez vu les
pays-bas a annoncé un plan de soutien à
l'hydrogène de 9,9 milliards d'euros 10
milliards pour l'allemagne 9 milliards
pour l'espagne 7 milliards pour la
france 7 milliards pour le portugal et
bientôt plusieurs dizaines de milliards
la chine ou potentiellement par les
états unis dans les années qui vont
venir et bien de fait vous avez des
gouvernements qui sont en train de dire
je suis en train de prendre des mesures
pour tout simplement aider à la
structuration de cette filière est
finalement permettre de baisser les prix
pour que cet hydrogène aujourd'hui gris
ou noir puisse être verdi et d'autre
part que cet hydrogène verts puissent
ensuite remplacé d'autres sources
d'énergie primaire alors c'est pas
facile évidemment et si je retourne en
arctique
que se passe-t-il en arctique et bien
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup je voulais
lead activités extractives qui ont lieu
vous le savez peut-être
l'arctique c'est l'une des grandes
nouvelles provinces pour les pétroliers
pour les gaziers et puis pour ceux qui
mènent des activités extractives en
général penser au charbon penser aux
mines pensé aux diamants penser alors à
l'uranium aux terres rares j'en passe et
des meilleurs donc aujourd'hui si vous
regardez ce qui se passe en arctique
donc matière d'énergie bien sûr ce que
vous allez voir c'est surtout un article
dans lequel vous allez trouver du gaz
naturel
beaucoup beaucoup de gaz naturel de plus
en plus de gaz naturel et en particulier
en russie mais pas que en alaska aussi
et potentiellement au groenland dans les
années à venir ou encore évidemment en
norvège
donc ça l'a finalement qu'est ce qu'on
peut en faire est ce que ce gaz de
l'arctique va décarbonés le reste de nos
civilisations et de nos économies
les partisans du gaz vous disent que oui
puisque les partisans du gaz vous dis
simplement si vous utilisez du gaz
naturel vous allait émettre 50 % de co2
en moins que du charbon
et si vous utilisez donc du gaz naturel
vous allez mettre 30 % de co2 en moins
que du pétrole donc c'est mieux que rien
sûr que vous le savez on est en ce
moment dans une course on est engagé
dans une course dans une urgence
climatique
donc est ce qu on a véritablement le
temps d'attendre de passer un premier
palier pour passer au gaz naturel
puis on va faire le deuxième palier pour
trouver la solution
évidemment la majorité de ceux qui
s'intéressent à la planète vont dire que
non les vasières poutine lui eût dit que
oui bien sûr
et du coup en arctique ce qu'on va
trouver c'est que au delà du gaz naturel
vous allez trouver à l'horizon 2030 2035
et plus de l'hydrogène alors qu'elle
hydrogène vous allez trouver en arctique
et bien tout simplement vous allez
trouver déjà de l'hydrogène carbonée
parce que tout simplement vous pouvez à
partir du gaz naturel de l'arctique
produire de l'hydrogène localement si
vous produisez cet hydrogène qu'on
appelle gris dont c'est à dire à partir
de gaz naturel et que vous lui
adjoignent et au moment de la synthèse
de l'hydrogène vous lui adjoignent et un
petit en fait c'est pas petit un filtre
qui la permet de séquestrer les
particules les molécules de carbone est
bien de fait vous allez pouvoir
décarbonés une partie de cet hydrogène
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'hydrogène bleus
mais vous pouvez faire peut-être un
petit peu mieux
c'est à dire que au lieu de continuer à
extract à extraire le gaz le pétrole le
charbon de l'arctique pour en faire de
l'hydrogène
ce qui au fond n'a pas non plus
énormément de sens d'un point de vue
climatique comme vous l'avez bien
compris et bien on pourrait passer à des
énergies renouvelables et la l'arctique
a encore beaucoup de potentiel puisque
en arctique vous avez des potentiel
éolien qui sont très forts dans
l'ensemble de la zone dans tous les
états de l'arctique
vous avez des potentiels en matière de
géothermie vous avez des potentiels
aussi en matière d'hydroélectricité
parce que oui là quand je bois un coup
pour vous c'est que de l'eau pour moi
c'est de l'énergie
donc du coup une fois qu'on a fait ça
qu'est ce qu'on s'est dit on s'est dit
que fondamentalement en arctique vous
pouviez aller plus loin que ce qui est
juste devant vos yeux
oui c'est de l'eau mais potentiellement
c'est l'hydrogène et comment vous faites
et hydrogène mais tout simplement vous
avez une source électrique renouvelable
qui peut être une éolienne qui peut être
une géothermie qui peut être autre chose
est tout simplement vous allez prendre
de l'eau et il y en a beaucoup
évidemment un article comme vous l'avez
compris vous allez faire passer un
courant électrique dedans et les
molécules à l'intérieur de l'eau
c'est-à-dire les molécules d'hydrogène
h2 et l'atom d'oxygène h2o est donc
simplement vont se séparer et vous allez
pouvoir conserver l'hydrogène est
conservée l'oxygène et valoriser tout
simplement les deux donc aujourd'hui en
arctique que vous soyez en russie en
alaska au groenland en norvège il y a un
intérêt qui est fort et les projets se
multiplient
et puis à de l'argent aussi pour pousser
ses projets alors pourquoi il ya autant
d'argent pourquoi il ya autant de
potentiel en arctique d'un point de vue
business par rapport à l'hydrogène
et bien tout simplement parce que les
pays de l'arctique
tous ont déjà des zones de production
d'électricité décarbonée où
l'électricité est en fait donc
décarbonés mais aussi abondante et pas
cher comme vous le voyez derrière moi en
islande 100 % de la production
électrique
c'est l'un des cinq pays au monde à être
dans ce cas là 500 % de la production
électrique provient d'énergies
renouvelables si vous allez ensuite un
petit peu plus à l'est en norvège s'est
pas 100% mais c'est 97%
si vous allez si vous retournez un petit
peu plus à l'ouest et que vous allez au
groenland vous allez retrouver 70 % si
vous allez en suède en finlande au
danemark c'est pareil vous allez avoir
des potentiels de production d'énergie
renouvelable relativement important à
partir desquels donc faire ce fameux
hydrogène vert et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'hydrogène est en train de
devenir un élément clé du développement
économique de l'arctique et attire les
capitaux du monde entier mais aussi
attire l'intérêt des puissances
l'arctique et des puissances non
arctiques pour inclure les sujets liés à
l'hydrogène dans la diplomatie de
l'arctique et en particulier au sein du
conseil de l'arctique est l'organe
diplomatique de référence dans la région
où il ya déjà deux programmes liés à
l'hydrogène
mais c'est pas aller seul et ce n'est
pas la seule région du monde où ça se
passe tout ça derrière moi ce que vous
voyez c'est une carte du monde qui vous
montre envers les pays qui ont déjà une
stratégie hydrogène il était à peine 10
en 2018
ils sont déjà plus d'une quinzaine en
et puis en orange surtout vous avez tous
les pays qui sont actuellement en train
de travailler à une stratégie hydrogène
qui devrait la publier soit en 2021 soit
en 2022
donc tout ça c'est encore une fois une
masse critique d'investisseurs de
décisionnaires de politique qui se met
en branle pour essayer avec l'hydrogène
de trouver une solution à cette histoire
de changer d'énergie pour une première
fois dans l'histoire de la civilisation
industrielle essayer de trouver une
énergie qui va remplacer les énergies
dominante et même en france même en
france toutes les régions françaises
à ce stade on une stratégie hydrogène la
seule région hexagonal qui n'a pas de
stratégie d'eugen à proprement parler
c'est la corse mais ça n'en fera pas
empêché la corse depuis 2012 déjà de
développer des programmes de soutien et
des programmes sur tout
de recherche liés à l'hydrogène en
milieu insulaire et puis je vous parle
même pas des outre-mer les outre-mer si
vous allez en guadeloupe si vous allez à
la martinique
si vous allez en guyane si vous allez à
la réunion en nouvelle-calédonie où même
à tahiti
vous allez trouver des programmes de
développement liés à l'hydrogène vert
donc lié à des énergies renouvelables
qui sont actuellement en train d'être
financés soutenu par la commission
européenne ou soutenu encore par des
acteurs publics ou privés internationaux
donc voilà tout ce qui se passe en
arctique et tout ce qui se passe dans
l'ensemble du monde
et puis de fait on en a déjà parlé et
puis c'est évidemment là aussi au coeur
de l'actualité
en france on est aussi très impliquée
sur la dimension de production avec par
exemple des capacités avec des sociétés
qui aujourd'hui sont capables de faire
des électrolyseurs donc les trois heures
c'est la machine qui va tout simplement
faire passer le réseau le courant
électrique dans l'eau pour séparer
l'explosition et l'hydrogène
en france on a des entreprises
aujourd'hui qui arrive à des taux de
rendement sur ces électrolyseur de 90 %
95 % voire 99 % grâce à plus de 15 ans
20 ans de travaux soutenus par la
puissance publique ou pas par des gens
tout simplement passionnés qui y
croyaient à l'hydrogène ya encore
longtemps et c'était le cas de mon père
qui avait investi dans l'hydrogène et
plus de vingt ans donc fondamentalement
quand aujourd'hui airbus fait le buzz ou
quand aéroports de paris par la halle
par de l'hydrogène ou quand des grandes
banques françaises par de l'hydrogène ou
évidemment totale ou technip par de
l'hydrogène
de fait c'est un mouvement de long terme
ça n'a pas tout ça n'est pas né il ya
seulement trois ans mais en réalité ce
qu'il faut vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà un voyage
qu'on peut faire avec de l'hydrogène et
c'est pas un voyage que tout le monde
peut faire mais c'est celui certainement
qui va faire le plus parler ces
prochaines années
c'est évidemment d'aller sur la lune
potentiellement sur mars
parce que de fait si vous voulez aller
sur la lune vivre sur un village lunaire
bah non seulement il faut l'hydrogène
pour y aller et puis vous faudra poster
de l'hydrogène aussi pour y survivre
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
oui